i know i know but i wish there was a way
that you the in-game was baked into it
that allowed you to make it more
difficult or to do certain things i just
i don't understand no i don't i don't i
don't think i
disagree with that because like i think
like purposely leaving it open-ended to
like how difficult you want it is what
makes that game so appealing to people
yeah if you put a difficulty like if you
went into a pokemon game and you were
like choose the difficulty immediately
people will be like uh
actually actually
in regards to difficulty i [ __ ] hate
choosing difficulty i hate it i do have
so much it depends on the game it
depends on the game because unlike so
some games it's it's completely stupid
and necessary right like first person
shooters like i hate it because it just
makes them more spongy yeah that's all
it does but on some games like pokemon
where it's like okay this
even even a 12 year old would probably
find this too easy like especially the
new one the new one was like the new
ones like hold your hand that's why it
was like beyond mine like even like you
know you you play players that's that's
a problem with the game itself right i
feel like i feel like this is a game
design yeah i feel like even adding 10
more difficulty to this is like what
like it's pokemon platinum i was playing
that i did another log but like even the
core game itself was actually kind of
challenging
it's not you can't just like fall asleep
and just spam one pokemon well that's
the thing right it's like i feel that's
the problem with just like pokemon games
in general where like like i played sun
and moon right that [ __ ] holds your hand
the entire song even as an adult and i'm
like dude like 10 year old me was crying
trying to get past like g3 of silver
right but and the game couldn't give a
[ __ ] like it was just like just get good
it's like figure it out yeah you're ten
you should start thinking bro stop
fighting [ __ ] ten year old scholars
i feel like nowadays people people have
less patience when it comes to
completing games yeah there's no there's
there's no way making a pokemon gym
slightly harder is hardly asking for
like like it's not we're not even dark
souls level of difficulties
i'm just you know there is you should in
a pokemon game i think even if you're
like 10 years old you should fail the
first gym probably and be forced to be
like maybe i should buy some potions
yeah maybe i should consider doing
something not just [ __ ] steamrolling
the [ __ ] with my mud cap every time just
give it like good game design so that
you don't have to say anything to get
the player to figure it out right yeah
it's like you know i just
even like when you're when i was like a
much younger kid you know when i was 10
whatever playing these games i hated it
when games were like completely like
steamrolly like you could just do it
without thinking yeah it's like having
some form of difficulty there is good
and it's also important i think for the
kid to learn
everything is gonna be [ __ ] easy yeah
exactly like i remember like when i was
[ __ ] like eight years old playing
mega man 2 for the first time yeah and i
was like this is [ __ ] impossible like
no one can beat this [ __ ] love that
game though that's one of my favorite
games of all time because i learned to
like i learned success through failure
kids have it too easy now these guys
is that as an adult i have absolutely
zero patience for games that are
[ __ ] hard right kids do not kids
will play the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah over
and over and over again because it's one
it's probably the only game they're
getting yeah and also there's nothing
it's it's not that's that's that's
that's what i'm trying it's not an email
that's the problem that's the point i'm
trying right
no because i feel like there's just
games are a lot more affordable nowadays
yeah back then you had one game every
few months maybe but it's still most if
they're getting like an xbox or
something okay yeah they can play
fortnite for free on it but if they want
to buy another game and it's difficult
they're probably going to try and
complete it because they bought the game
when they wanted it for christmas or
something right adults try to understand
kids
i'm just thinking from my perspective i
don't know maybe maybe i mean most of
them are just happy with like fortnite
and stuff right yeah
but i mean
i think the other thing as well is that
at least with like the old games is that
you know because they could only be
so long that they literally had to be
like all right this game if you blast
through it you could probably complete
in less than an hour exactly but like we
want you to play this game for a long
time so we're just going to make it
[ __ ] hard to the point where 40
minutes of gameplay is going to take you
about 40 days oh there are a lot of
[ __ ] moments in a lot of older games
oh yeah and i i remember thinking back
and i'm thinking how the [ __ ] did i like
play so many like levels of battle toad
and controversy play battle i did play
battle tonight it's actually a really
fun game it's a good game yeah it's a
[ __ ] great game
like to this day as like i remember
playing the [ __ ] motorbike
like the
hoverboard
overboard
i think i played it like for a full week
yeah in my room trying to complete that
[ __ ] level yeah because i remember
beating mega man 2
lots of times as a kid yeah and then i
recently played it a couple years ago i
could barely get past [ __ ] wood man
yeah i'm like how the [ __ ] did i do this
as a tenure oh it's because i literally
spent like a month of my life just
grinding also i couldn't play mega man
of my age i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
carpool tunnel like i like i tried
playing mega man x i'm just like oh i'm
getting a [ __ ] crap here if i'm just
like doing
doing like the wall jump jesus christ oh
my god
that's great though i love it i i guess
i'm i guess i'm angry that i'm getting
older and these children games aren't
getting older with me yeah i guess so i
i mean i like with difficulty i like i
i've i i now like when a game has just
like one set difficulty even if it's
like i i i i'm so like i get anxious
that with any game or any piece of media
where i want to enjoy it the most right
i want i wanted to enjoy the most on my
first playthrough and sometimes i've had
games where i loaded up and i hit i hit
the difficulty level selection and i'm
just like
i'm getting anxiety just now i'm already
getting anxiety you know what maybe i'll
play this game another time this is why
i like games even if they have
difficulty options they let you just
change it on the fly yeah yeah yeah
consequences for it and it's like all
right well this cut this section's kind
of [ __ ] i'm gonna knock it down how
do you feel about people who like
purposely select like easy mode
well like it depends on the game there's
some games where i'm like you're
actually just like not playing the game
if you pick price because it's far too
easy but like there's that whole like
stigma i i guess like connotation
they're like oh you're not you're not a
real gamer if you're playing it on
youtube you could scrub like levels of
things but i mean it's
obviously if i was there in the room
with them i'd be like almost wrong
little baby you're not gonna
click normal but you
and if if a general audience asked me
i'd be like yeah of course well you can
pick whatever difficulties you want yeah
right but obviously if you're my mate
i'm gonna i'm gonna write play play baby
mode mario oh yeah yeah i'm like you are
you playing mario kart mode no you're
not no no no no no no no no no no yeah i
mean it's different right actually
you'll poke fun at your friends yeah
[ __ ] around with that but i obviously in
general i think that you can play
whatever [ __ ] difficulty you want all
right
why would it why would i can why does
take away from me just have fun just
have fun if you want to be a little baby
[ __ ] you could be a little baby [ __ ] i
i don't care you have the right to do
that you paid the strength you have the
right to be a baby [ __ ] you pay for 60
bucks you get to do it yeah you know
so you know i think it's it's good
because not everyone you know obviously
some people have disabilities as well
they can't play the game on the hardest
difficulty
they can't do it you know i just think
accessibility is good in gaming